welcome back is still with Sean I was
born and Cody nickel and joining us is
the former Royal Marine Ben McBean who
served in Afghanistan at the same time
as Harry and conservative MP and chair
of the defense select committee Tobias
Elwood and they're going to be talking
primarily about Harry's boast that he
killed 25 Taliban and called them chess
pieces something which has not only
enraged many of his former colleagues in
the armed forces but has also enraged
the pretty much the entire Muslim world
and who knows what repercussions may
come from that stupid boat so we still
come tonight Harry's truth has come a
long way and we'll be talking that in a
moment this first is Sharon let me just
pick up with you because you were
directly involved in all this this goes
back to the Oprah Winfrey interview
and it's absolutely crystal clear in
that interview what Meghan Markle was
saying supported by Harry that someone
in the royal family had expressed
concern about the unborn baby skin color
and when probed by Oprah if what if the
if the skin color was too dark that
would be a problem Meghan Markle said
you may well deduce that yes right that
became the biggest story of all these
Revelations is that the family is racist
yes now we're supposed to believe that's
never what they intended Harry says that
Trisha Goddard says it there's now a
kind of whole revisionist thing going on
but this had real consequences I didn't
believe it at the time and I had to
leave my job but just believing what was
being said you then had to leave your
job because I was supporting you because
he supported my right to free speech he
didn't agree with me yeah right um You
had to go what do you feel about this
um
it's all it's all just craziness going
around and around and he he's turned his
life and the Royal Family's life into a
soap opera it's like a really bad
distance I mean it's always been so
bright but I think what's different is
he's always been speculative soap opera
right you know part of the thing of the
papers he goes on and on and on and all
these interviews and the book I had to
go through all this the the Press are
just evil the devil he calls them all
this kind of stuff and yet the Press
without them without the press it
wouldn't be a royal family with other
press doing predominant I mean I
remember the courage of his wedding
couldn't have been more Universal phrase
it was beautiful he could barely bring
himself do we even acknowledge that
right this guy is so blindly hateful of
the media and British press in
particular even though he gets exactly
the same coverage in many parts of the
world but when you I mean you haven't
read the whole thing I know but I have
this is I've never read anyone high
profile talk about their family like
this all of them his dad I know his
stepmom I know brother his sister-in-law
the Queen's dresser cops it yeah and
there's a really bad bit in here which I
really disliked which is very revealing
about his character where he trashes the
matron at Love Grove School so he names
as Pat he calls her greasy and ugly
didn't make the boys horny right and
says that uh you know just carries on
disparaging her she had a disability
with her spine which made her she had to
walk and he used to mock her uh mock the
way she couldn't walk properly and he
boasts about this this is a guy who on
his website for Archer World their
Foundation describes as you know
standing for compassion
where's the compassion in any of this I
think well listen I'm just hearing you
picking up that story and you know I was
reporting on Harry when he was falling
in and out of nightclubs getting into
brawls with Paparazzi I mean I remember
speaking to the mother of one girl who
was dating he said he really just was
was implied he was he was rude he turned
up drunk with sick on him they didn't
want him around their goal okay and and
that was understandable this is clearly
a man who feels that he's gone through a
metamorphosis a massive reinvention and
has come out on the other side but what
was so interesting I felt about watching
the interview with Tom Bradley and I
think Bradley did a very robust very
good job with him was when he didn't
mention the Metallica it's not the
racist allegations as he rightly did but
it was very clear that when Harry was
almost steered off into a Zone where he
wasn't comfortable or he couldn't
Channel his his therapy speaking
everything else he looked very
uncomfortable and I want to make just
one quick point on these racism
allegations I think this is very
important
when this turned into the biggest race
rail that this country has been in as
long as I can remember and the most
troubling storm for the royal family
Harold Megan came out and made it clear
in a subsequent statement that they were
not talking about the queen or Prince
Philip because of course this Witch Hunt
ensued that would have been an ample
opportunity we said and by the way this
wasn't an allegation or charge of racism
it was one of unconscious bias I think
what's happened is he realized too late
because there's a report that he tried
to get the book withdrawn that actually
this was all going too far I think I
mean the fact he hasn't mentioned that
in here the single most explosive
Revelation isn't in the book nor is this
supposed thing with the with the palace
denying Megan help for her Suicidal
Thoughts to make two very very major
emissions well they were the two biggest
they were the two biggest Bombshells
neither are in his book of his life let
me bring in Ben you fantastic service to
your country as a royal marine and you
were severely wounded in the process
thank you first of all for your amazing
service and it's great to see you you
know Harry you know you fought alongside
him in Afghanistan what do you make of
this
um yeah in particular the boasting about
killing 25 Taliban yeah I wasn't with
her in Afghanistan I was in a whole
different area
um
the 25
body count thing it's just it was
obviously him in context telling a story
and he mentioned the number but I think
he could have told the story very easily
without mentioning that number I don't
think it was boasting
um but at the same time if you say it
and give a number to it aren't you just
boasting I mean whichever way you're
trying to describe it he's just
literally saying what he's done which
was his job and thank God because that
was why we were able to get out of there
kind of thing because we called him and
it helped us out but I don't think
mention that number was wise would you
ever do that
no I mean the difference is before I
killed ten thousand men no one cares but
if he killed one everyone cares so it's
not wise for him to mention it it's a
bit like poking a bear as you walk past
that there's no point in
that's not doing any favors um so I
don't think he's boasting it but I just
I think there's he could have easily
have said what he said without
mentioning that number and on the
specific
um racism thing was your understanding
just as a member of the public
when you watched did you watch the Oprah
interview not a lot of it you saw the
you saw the clips yeah yeah yeah was
your run was your impression that they
were saying that someone had been racist
about the skin color of their child I'll
be honest it did come across that way a
bit
um and then obviously when the media
jumped in it it I didn't think I wonder
who was racist like because it kind of
come across that way um the thing is
just in my opinion um it's almost like
you don't go to like a comedy show and
the Comedian says a joke that you don't
like and you're offend you're offended
by it
um you can say that you're offended but
the comedian doesn't have to care so you
just kind of get mad kind of thing it
seems like that's like Billy's family
like he's obviously not happy with
certain things and he might have said it
to them and they may not they don't have
to care they don't have to respond or
apologize because his feelings get hurt
so then he's kind of moved away supposed
to be happy in America but he's not
clearly he's not happy is it no so then
he's kind of attacking his family by
revealing everything waiting for like an
apology but you're not gonna get one I
just think everyone defending him I just
think if it was their family
and someone was going on television
because they had some kind of profile
and was just doing this endlessly
trashing the family all of them I mean
it would you know you would I think most
people would cut one person I I still
think Harry's great I think a lot of
troops do you can't take away what he's
done for this country morning no no you
can't
um but yes he's far out with his family
but we don't need to now see all of this
because it's so funny I just think even
though I love Harry's great guy from
what I know what I've seen I don't have
to support every move that he makes
including this one because it's not very
nice I think that's very honest and I
think you're quite right I don't
denigrate his service you know my
brother-in-law trained him at Sandhurst
he was a colonel in charge of William
and Harry uh they're training there so
they were both very good very good young
soldiers nothing nothing I've never
denigrated that at all let's bring in
Tobias Elwood the conservative MP and
chair of the defense select committee
Tobias you've actually worked with Harry
on the Invictus games which again is an
incredibly admirable thing the Invictus
games and I've always completely
supported it but when he said this stuff
about the Taliban you can see from the
reaction already around the Muslim world
the way it's been now latched on to by a
lot of Islamic fundamentalists and
preachers and so on this is going to
potentially cause huge security problems
not least I would think at an event like
the Invictus games
yeah I think you're right officially I
just wanted to stress the important
relationship there is between our
monarchy it goes back uh Millennia in
fact we saw that at the funeral for the
the queen and indeed we'll see that in
the coronation you know for the king
coming up that's a powerful bond between
all of our armed forces the three
services and I pay tribute to anybody
your brother and so forth Ben who's
there in the studio with you anybody
that steps forward uh to represent their
country uh and put where the uniform
that includes Prince Harry he did two
tours of Afghanistan and you're right
this huge Legacy the big thing that he
created the Invictus games has been
quite incredible but I think he was
ill-advised to talk about a kill count
we argue that we have the most
professional armed forces in the world
that's absolutely right that's not just
because of our combat Effectiveness it's
also how we conduct ourselves in the
aftermath of battle following the
genific conventions following the rules
of engagements how we deal with the
prisoners of War how we deal with the
injured who are actually served in Camp
Bastion as well in the hospital there
next to the you know the British
comrades and indeed how we deal with the
dead as well we don't go and join the
armed forces to kill people we go there
to defend we go there to uphold you know
democracy and the rule of law a
byproduct of that is the occasional
necessity use of lethal Force so for the
reasons as you've pointed out I think
this has caused difficulties not least
where we've left Afghanistan we've
seeded this back to the very people we
went into the defeat the talban
themselves we have 40 million Afghans
that we still need to have a
relationship with we've got the Halo
trust for example a fantastic charity
that's doing mine clearance there all
these organizations still have to work
have a relationships
that extremists will take I would say
that his what he's said here and the way
he's expressed himself according them
chess pieces saying he killed 25 and so
on as a senior member of the royal
family which he remains I think that has
I mean the irony of this he has gone on
about security and protection for his
family never mind anybody else for the
last two years arguing he should have
more protection how does this kind of
statement in a book do anything but put
his own family at more risk it also puts
the royal family in totality I would say
at more risk from any lunatic
fundamentalist who wants to exact some
kind of Revenge for what he's said the
Invictus games and events like it might
become targets his own military you know
he might still have friends in the
military you know they they are now
walking around with a bigger Target on
the back because a senior member of the
royal family has come out boasting about
killing the talent man and how many he
killed and dehumanized them as chess
pieces yeah
I think it would be wise for Prince
Harry to provide clarification as to
what he meant there if you read The
Wider passes it's the only bit of the
book that I've read he clearly
understands what his mission was the
bigger picture as well what he was
fighting for but those particular lines
I understand it was written the book by
a ghost writer it was put in there to
sensationalize and as you've articulated
this can have serious ramifications not
least for the Invictus games which I
stress it was a pleasure to work with
Prince Harry in Toronto and indeed in
Sydney Sydney an important aspect of
Rehabilitation of those who have served
our serving but have been injured or
somehow you know need to be
rehabilitated I hope that continues I
hope this will not affect that important
creation that Prince Harry can be very
proud of tomorrow thank you very much
Sharon before we go to the break just
this question there's a correlation
coming up in May the coronation work
King Charles will be coronated Harry
said he was a terrible father couldn't
handle being a single parent father at
all
um you know constant sniping at him in
the book he absolutely trashes Camilla
as a dangerous villain she's getting
crowned as well as the queen consort
she's a stepmother and he won't give a
clear no I'm not going to go and the
palace haven't said he won't be invited
I can't imagine in what world these two
Megan and Harry think they're going to
waltz in to the Westminster Abbey is it
well there is to watch a coronation the
two people are distracting a book there
will be
um an invitation I'm quite sure the
coronation because actually in this
situation Charles has to be magnanimous
in last night's interview Harry spoke
about the need for the royal family to
be unified and Charles knows that this
rift at the heart of the world but I
wouldn't trust them not to then do
another book another series but you know
what I think honestly if he comes to
this country in the next few months I
think he'll be booed it was booed last
time well he was I mean a little bit he
won even by Harry's brass next time
walking into the scene of the coronation
of two people one in particular your
father's wife the queen council is about
to be around Wicked Woman I mean it's
just it's unto me it's unconscionable
you'd have the brass I think it's
possible that they can go and it can be
orchestrated in such a way as was the
Platinum Jubilee celebrations where they
were away from his brother I don't think
they should be anywhere near it I think
and I don't think they should be allowed
to have their Royal titles anymore bang
done you want to do this you want to do
this Harry you don't get to keep the
Duke that goes everything goes anyway
more importantly Ben thank you great to
see you good appreciate your service
your country proper hero this man good
to have you on the show thank you